Before our story begins, let's remember how it used to be. Jacky lived in the South Side in a Black neighborhood. City didn't enforce the housing code properly, didn't investigate arsons.
There would be fires going on in Woodlawn daily, several times a day. And it was just fire engines all the time. And so my daughter started to believe that when buildings got old and died, like people got old and died-- that you knew a building was old and was dying because it would burn up.
Before our story begins, Chicago was run by the Democratic machine, and Black aldermen, like Danny Davis, would turn out to vote for the machine election after election. But the machine didn't reward the Black wards for those votes the way it paid back the white wards on the North Side with street cleanings and sewers, with newly paved roads and sidewalks, economic development money.
Well, actually, we had called the areas colonies. And just basically picking up the garbage in these wards, just trying to keep them clean was a real problem. The person who was elected, there would be so much focus on garbage pickup that you'd almost have to just be the garbage alderman. I recall telling people time and time again that I was tired of just being the garbage alderman.
Before our first story begins, the Chicago political machine squeezed Black kids into mobile trailers behind public schools rather than let them attend white schools just blocks away. Before our story begins, the Chicago machine built high-rise public housing to hold Blacks on the South Side and keep them from moving into white neighborhoods.
Before our story begins, the Chicago political machine built a system of highways that coincidentally divided Black neighborhoods from white and particularly insulated the mayor's all-white neighborhood, Bridgeport. Typical inequities-- unemployment in the white 11th Ward was 0%. Unemployment in the 4th Ward, where Blacks lived, was 25%.
This is a story about one ethnic group doing what so many other ethnic groups have done in this country-- put its own candidate in City Hall, won the mayor's office. But because this ethnic group happened to be Black, what happened was unlike anything that happens when an Italian politician or an Irish politician or a Jewish politician take City Hall. White voters deserted their own political party. White politicians tried to stage a public, slow-motion coup. And the mayor faced pressures that were different from those faced by any white mayor of any city in America.
And this little parable of race and politics in America does not take place in some distant, pre-civil-rights past. It happened just 10 years ago here in Chicago.
Good evening. You're on with Harold Washington.
Good evening. Mr. Washington, could you clear up a point for me? I understand that once you move into city hall, you're going to remove all the elevator boxes and replace them with vines. Is that true?
What? Replace them with what?
With vines.
Vines, V-I-N-E-S?
You know what?
No, no.
I'm not even going to ask you why. And--
No, I don't think we have 3 million Tarzans in this city.
Good evening. Randall is gone.
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. November 25 is the 10th anniversary of the death of Chicago's first Black mayor, Harold Washington. He died early in his second term of office. Today we remember his story and ask why the largest cities in the country-- New York, Los Angeles, Chicago-- no longer have Black mayors. Act One of our program is about the past. Act Two is about the present and the future.
A word about the voices you're going to be hearing over the course of this hour-- it's mostly people who were close to Harold Washington, many of them activists and politicians-- Lu Palmer, Judge Eugene Pincham, Congressman Danny Davis, then Alderman Eugene Sawyer. There are people from his administration, Jacky Grimshaw, Grayson Mitchell, Timuel Black, and some reporters who followed his story-- Vernon Jarrett, Monroe Anderson, Gary Rivlin, and Laura Washington, who later became his press secretary. There will also be an occasional opponent or voter. Stay with us.
Act One, Yesterday. For decades, Chicago politics had been run with an iron hand by the legendary political boss, Richard J. Daley. Our story begins just after his death in 1976, when the machine was sputtering a bit with no strong leader and the possibility-- a small possibility-- of change. To give you a sense of what it meant to be a loyal Black alderman in the Chicago machine at that time, consider what happened in City Hall the day Richard Daley died.
By tradition, the president pro tem of the city council should at least occupy the mayor's office until such time as a process was determined for the election of a new mayor.
And who was the--
That was Wilson Frost--
Black alderman.
--a loyal Black alderman from the 34th Ward, a Daley Democrat, a lawyer, impeccable reputation, impeccable credentials. The only mis-qualification he had was he's Black. God ordained that he be born Black. And the power structure sent police officers to the fifth floor, armed, to sit at the door to prevent Frost from even entering the mayor's office. That was a tremendous insult.
It was an insult, but it was not unusual. The white machine picked who the Black leaders would be. And mostly, those leaders did what they were told. Blacks in Chicago had nowhere to go but the Democratic machine. They were stuck. But then there were a series of famous and especially infuriating insults from the white political establishment. Biggest among them-- Black voters finally elected an anti-machine candidate named Jane Byrne, who, once in office, betrayed them, sucked up to the white machine, made appointments and decisions specifically to prove she was not in the pocket of Black Chicago.
Then circumstances came together-- some by planning, some by luck-- that made it possible to elect a Black mayor. The planning-- organizers registered over 100,000 minority voters, held rallies and meetings, declaring it was time to elect a Black mayor. The luck-- two white candidates split the white vote. One more piece of luck-- the Chicago Democratic Party had created, in spite of itself, Harold Washington. Vernon Jarrett was an old friend and a local newspaper columnist.
And Harold was in that party now. Don't forget, Harold had been a precinct captain. His father had groomed him as a precinct captain since he was-- what-- 11 years old. But his father was done wrong. So Harold is an unusual person in that he nursed this resentment of how the Democratic Party had deserted his father at one time, when his father ran for alderman of the 3rd Ward.
He was a confused guy, got a little sense of mission in him and wanting to do the right thing. But yet, he was balanced off by this pragmatism that you got to play ball, to a degree, with the organization. And he was correct. He wouldn't have made it without the Democratic machine.
Usually, in Chicago, political activists had a choice. They could go with politicians who were good on the issues but then had no political experience dealing with the machine, or they could get hacks, who knew the machine but were terrible in the issues. Washington was the rarest kind of politician-- delivered on the issues, knew the machine-- which was why, in fact, he did not want the job. Lu Palmer was at the center of the effort to draft a Black mayor.
Well, we talked to Harold. He was reluctant, very reluctant. At the time, he was in Congress and was enjoying being a congressman.
Enjoying it partly because he was far from the machine.
He set some requirements, how much money we'd have to raise. We'd have to get 50,000 new voters.
He asked that, thinking, well, you'll never get that or--
He used 50,000 knowing that no way in the world are they going to come up with 50,000 new-- and that was hard in those days, to come up with 50,000 registered voters.
They registered 130,000 new voters.
May I jump ahead a moment? You know what put Harold Washington over with the broad masses of Black people was when they had the primary debates.
Oh, the triumph was the televised debate.
Because you had Daley. You had Byrne. And then you had somebody who could talk-- Harold.
Let's review that lineup. Daley was Richard M. Daley, son of the late mayor, Richard J. Daley. He is, by the way, our current mayor here in Chicago. Byrne was Jane Byrne, the then-incumbent mayor. And Harold-- you already know Harold. Those were the three Democratic contenders in the mayoral race. It is the fall of 1983. Here's a typical exchange between them. The three of them were asked at one point what they would do, if anything, about the police department's Office of Professional Standards, the place in the police department which handles complaints about police misconduct and brutality.
Jane Byrne and Richard Daley sound basically like normal politicians. They offer dull truisms like--
I believe that the members of the police board, chaired by Reverend Wilbur Daniels, really do take that job very seriously. And I--
Here is the most specific that Richard Daley, then state's attorney, got that day.
I think, like anything else, there must be improvement. And there is nothing wrong with improvement in the Office of Professional Standards.
[APPLAUSE]
When Harold Washington comes on, what is most noticeable is that he sounds like a human being.
The side's question is, what would I do to improve the Office of Professional Standards? When I answer it, I'll be the only one who answered the question.
[CHEERING]
The Office of Professional Standards was arrived at after a long and tortuous situation in this city in which members-- not all, but members-- of the Chicago Police Department consistently refused to be adequate and professional in their handling of Hispanic, Black people. It's just that simple. It's a long-standing--
What happened was, he became plausible to the Black community. Suddenly, they heard somebody who was articulate, knew what he was talking about, and was forceful.
In the first place, the appointees, all but nine, are political appointees. Many of the investigators are wedded to or related to police members of the Chicago Police Department.
A lot of people, Black people, had felt all along that we've been bossed by dunderheads. They are not that bright. They don't know that much. And Harold, Harold Washington, standing there between Jane Byrne and Richard M. Daley, the son, so cool, so well read that people, Black people, were just thrilled. It was like watching Michael Jordan with a basketball.
Mr. Brzeczek, unfortunately, at the behest of this mayor, as a minion of this mayor, as a subaltern of this mayor, as a subordinate of this mayor, has destroyed his credibility--
Harold used to use words that even some of these journalists, these white journalists, had to scratch their head and go to the dictionary. Black people loved that.
And he jumped on Jane Byrne and took her by surprise, shocked her. And she was still reeling from the shock. And I shall never forget it, that night. I said, this man's got it made. He's in.
Here's one way that being a Black candidate for office is different from being a white candidate. If you're Black, you get thrown into the chasm of misunderstanding that divides white America for Black America, in a way that white politicians almost never are. Two Americas simply see certain things differently. For instance, what should Harold Washington say about the late mayor, Richard J. Daley? Many white Chicagoans still held him in awe, while Black and Latino Chicago, for good reasons, had a different take. Well, here's what Harold decided to say.
When he says that he would hope that I would have all the good qualities of past mayors, there are no good qualities of past mayors to be had-- none, none, none.
[APPLAUSE]
None. I did not mourn at the bar of the late mayor. I regret anyone dying. I have no regrets about him leaving. He was a racist from the core, head to toe and hip to hip. There's no dangerous doubt about it. And he spewed and fought and oppressed Black people to the point that some of them thought that was the way they were supposed to live, just like some slaves on the plantation thought that was the way they were supposed to live.
It was just like everything else he did and said. It was historic. And no one would challenge the late mayor on anything, much less call him that kind of name. And I think that was what made him so provocative. It's what made him so loved by the people who supported him and so hated by the people who wanted to deny him the office. He didn't mince any words.
I'd give no hosannas to a racist, nor do I appreciate or respect his son. If his name were anything other than Daley, his campaign would be a joke. He has nothing to offer anybody but a bent-up, tin-can smile, no background.
[APPLAUSE]
And he runs on the legacy of his name, an insult to common sense and decency. Everything I've ever got in the world, I work for it. Nobody gave me anything.
The primary taught him that he could transcend being the third candidate, of being the Black candidate. And he could take that Adam Powell positioning. He could take that Marcus Garvey positioning, where you're a hybrid between the politician and the public man. And you become somewhere between Muhammad Ali, Michael Jackson, somewhere in superstar.
And although I may sound abrasive, I have no malice toward anybody. I have a job to do. I've got place to go and things to do. And I approach this job just like any masterful surgeon when you have to cut out a cancer. I cut it out with no emotion. Get it out. Get it out.
[APPLAUSE]
This dominant culture may have messed up my pocket, but they haven't messed up my head one bit. I believe in the powers of redemption. And I simply cannot believe in the God I worship, that He would permit us to sit on this Earth for 400 years-- or, rather, in this country for 400 years-- and suffer the indignities which we have suffered, piled time after time, higher after higher, and so heavy, it has almost broken the backs of one of the most powerful people in this world. I can't believe there is no redemption.
But that redemption is not going to come out in hatred. It's going to come out in positive attitude toward our fellow man. We've come into the 1980s with an understanding that we have not just a right but a responsibility to give the best that we have to a society. We want to give it. And we're going to give it if we have to beat them across the head, knock them down, and make them take it. We're going to give it to them.
[APPLAUSE]
During this election and during Harold Washington's terms as mayor, in Chicago, every day was the day after the OJ verdict. Every day was a day when Black and white Chicago took a look at the same set of facts and drew two different conclusions. For instance, when the media raised questions about Washington's past, it made white Chicagoans question his qualifications for office, but it made minority voters more loyal.
In 1983, when Harold announced his candidacy, 95% of Black people never heard of him. And what happened was, the white power structure media first criticized Harold for having been convicted of a tax violation. He failed to file his returns.
We should be precise about this. It wasn't that he hadn't paid. It's that he hadn't filed the return.
He hadn't filed a return. That's right. He paid withholding. There was nothing to it. So what difference does it make? But the point is, when this occurred, it gave him publicity that he otherwise would not have gotten. Many people in the Black community resented the criticism being leveled against him.
They then said, well, you're not married. You can't be mayor if you're not married. We made Jane Byrne married McMullen. We made Jim Thompson married Jane Thompson. We made Kennedy, in the Senate, go back to his wife. You cannot be a viable politician if you're not married.
Here, again, he did something that Blacks aren't accustomed to seeing Blacks do. He stood up. And he said, I'm not going to get married. Everybody thought, man, go marry if this is going to make-- and he said, I'm not. Nobody can tell me to marry. I don't want to marry. My marital status has nothing to do with my qualifications as mayor.
And here, again, the Black community looked at him with a great deal more respect now. Because many of the people, Black folks, said mayor don't want to be married no way. So they said, go on, Harold.
[LAUGHTER]
But he got some more publicity. And quite frankly, you will have to concede-- I certainly will say it-- that had a white candidate with the same baggage been running, there's no way in the world he would have been elected mayor.
How do you figure that?
Well, it's true. Your white candidate who'd been in jail for failing to file a tax return, who wasn't married, rumored to be homosexual-- everybody knew Harold wasn't a homosexual, but that was the rumor they tried to create-- and a disbarred lawyer? No way in the world, if he was white, would he be elected.
And what should we think of that?
What I think of it? I think it's here again-- well, if South Africa can elect a man who's a felon--
Nelson Mandela.
Nelson Mandela, 27 years.
[LAUGHTER]
You know what's interesting about it-- is that none of those criticisms also go to what the white fear was. I wonder, as far as you could tell, what was at the heart of the white fear?
Because he's Black.
And so the two Chicagos headed to primary day, white Chicago mostly ignoring the Washington candidacy, Black Chicago abuzz about it. And when he won, the two Chicagos had wildly different reactions, as you might expect. Monroe Anderson was a reporter at The Chicago Tribune at the time. He was one of the few Blacks who worked in the newsroom the day after Harold Washington's primary victory.
There was such a somber feeling around that place. It was like somebody's family member, beloved family member, had died or something. It was just really somber. And we were in this jubilant mood, except you did not feel comfortable expressing it, looking it.
So we walked around, (SINGING) doo, doo, doo, doo, doo, doo, doo. (SPEAKING) And then we would go into somebody's office or someplace aside and go, yes, and jump up and down and then come out and walk around. Oh, yes. We're reporters too. Yes, we understand. [LAUGHS]
After primary day, things got ugly. Usually, winning the Democratic primary for mayor in Chicago means you've won the office. The Republican Party doesn't count in city elections. But in this case, as Chicago moved toward the general election in April 1983, 90% of white Chicago deserted the Democratic Party to vote for a Republican named Bernie Epton. One of his campaign slogans-- "Epton, before it's too late."
Black Chicago saw the Democratic defections as racism, pure and simple. Meanwhile, white policemen circulated hate literature illustrated with chicken bones and watermelons. And in perhaps the most famous incident in the campaign, while stumping with Walter Mondale, Harold Washington stopped at St. Pascal's church on the city's white northwest side.
It was almost a riot.
Monroe Anderson covered it for the Tribune.
When Harold showed up and the press entourage showed up, there was this angry-- people were, like, approaching the car. People were out of control. I thought that we were in physical danger. And then we get to the church, and somebody spray painted on the church graffiti that said, "Die, nigger, die."
On a Catholic Church?
Yes.
Meanwhile, something curious happened. Occasionally, Harold Washington or one of his supporters would say, in passing, something like, it's our turn now. And when they did, it made headlines. White Chicago and the mainstream press saw it as more than just ethnic pride. It was seen as threatening. This is one of the ways that being a Black politician in America is different than being a Polish politician or an Irish politician. Judge Pincham.
The difference is very, very simple. And that is, when the Polish attempt to get a Polish mayor, it's good ethnic politics. When the Irish try to get an Irish mayor, it's good ethnic politics. But when the Blacks try to get a Black mayor, it's racism.
Glenn Leonard grew up in the white southwest side of Chicago, didn't vote for Harold Washington.
I think a lot of people thought that he was going to bring in a lot of people that were going to be Black and were going to change the city. Now we have our chance. Now let's go ahead and do it. Let's right all these so-called wrongs. Whether they were right or wrong, it's another story. Let's right these wrongs. Let's move in. Let's take over. Let's have more of a say in the local government. And people just saw that as a threat. They thought, well, these people are going to come in, move into the corner house or whatever, and another white flight starts again. I think that that was a big fear.
Chicago will become another Detroit, people said, another Cleveland. Property values would fall, businesses leave. Many whites had already fled one set of neighborhoods during white flight. And Glenn says that white Chicago was used to having the late Mayor Daley protect their neighborhoods, for instance, by blocking federal schemes to bring in low-income public housing all over the city. But Harold Washington wouldn't do that.
He was going to, obviously, no longer block these. And these low-income housing units would come into every neighborhood in the city or whatever. And that would start the ball rolling in your-- what do they call it in the Far East when the communists-- the domino effect. Thank you. [LAUGHS]
This is one thing that Black politicians have to deal with that white politicians don't. And this is true from Chicago to Washington, DC, from North Carolina to South Africa. They have to deal with white fear. Harold Washington.
We have 670,000 Black registered voters in this city. When you get right down to it, the votes are here. They're here. They're here. And every group-- and I've said it before, and I'll say it again. And the press takes it and runs out in left field with it. Every group that gets our percentage of the population, they don't go around begging. They don't go around explaining. They don't have any excuses to make. They just move on in and take one of their own and put them in office. That's what we should do. That's what democracy is all about.
Problem is, when your opponents don't see your election, it's just the normal workings of democracy. How Harold Washington tried to rise above their fear after he squeaked out a narrow victory in the general election and took office, that's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Most weeks on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different stories on that theme. But today, we're breaking from our usual format to bring you this parable about race and politics in America, the story of Harold Washington, Chicago's first Black mayor, who entered office in 1983 and died just four years later, just a few months into his second term. November 25 is the 10th anniversary of his death.
So in Chicago and in most American big cities, the way it used to work-- and I say used to with some reservations. In Chicago, you could argue that it still works this way. The way it used to work was that when Irish-Americans took the mayor's office, or Italian-Americans, or Polish-Americans, they channeled contracts and patronage jobs and other municipal goodies to their own communities. Lu Palmer was one of the people at the center of the movement to elect a Black mayor in Chicago. He convened the early organizational meetings in his basement. It is hard to imagine that Harold Washington would have ever come to office without him. And he was disappointed by Harold.
I don't know. But he never became what I would consider the Black mayor. Black people wanted something that was so simple-- fairness. And I used to get upset with Harold after he became elected, because Harold was too fair. In fact, he would say in his speeches, I'm going to be fair. I'm going to be more than fair.
No one, but no one in this city, no matter where they live or how they live, is free from the fairness of our administration. We'll find you and be fair to you wherever you are.
And I used to cringe--
But I need your help.
--when he would say, I'm not only going to be fair, but I'm going to be fairer than fair. Well, come on. You don't have to go overboard. And Harold did.
Those of us who are considered radicals, we simply believe that since the Daleys, Byrne, and all the rest of the white mayors had always put white people first, with any question, without any apology, we said that Harold got to put Black people first. And that's what we wanted.
I'm not sure we wanted to be to white people what Daley was to Black people. That is, he was just ridiculous. And the present Daley-- same way. But people, they wanted to see the opportunity to have our community thrive like other communities.
It wasn't just Black nationalists like Lu Palmer who felt this way. Old-time machine loyalists, like Eugene Sawyer, who was the Black alderman that the white Democratic machine wanted to succeed Harold Washington as mayor, said the same thing.
And that was part of the things, that I think we probably were too fair. I think Harold was too fair.
In what way?
A lot of people think he was too fair, by giving a lot more and giving everybody the same thing. And people didn't expect it. A lot of Black folks think that you should have given your own people a little bit more.
Well, a major problem with being a Black person in America--
Reporter Monroe Anderson.
--is you're in this trap. Because-- and this is sort of our curse and our blessing because of this racial history, is that we have been complaining and pointing out all these inequities for a very long time. And therefore, all these things that you have pointed out that have been an injustice to you, now that you're in power, you can't do because it'll be injustice to whites. And therefore, the rules have to be this great, even, everything's fair and square.
People close to Harold Washington say that it was smart politics for him to be fairer than fairer. After all, Black wards had been treated so unfairly in the past that simply giving them the same services that the rest of the city got would be a huge step forward. It was also the political stance he felt most comfortable with by disposition. And when Black politicians or community activists came to City Hall, trying to get more for one neighborhood over another, he was so enormously popular in Black Chicago, where 85% of the Black electorate turned out to vote for him, and where everyone simply referred to him as Harold, that he could ignore the pressure. Jacky Grimshaw was a staff person.
I think there is a difference between the Black population and the Black politicians. I think, on the part of the Black politicians, it was definitely, it's our turn. And I had to deal with some of these folks. They'd come in, and they want 10 jobs and crap like that. Hey, there ain't 10 jobs. But I think on the part of the people, they were into fairness. I think the fairness thing played with them. They were proud of Harold. They supported him, what he was doing.
Privately, Harold Washington talked about the danger of doing away with the old patronage system, how it could make the first Black mayor weaker than any of his white predecessors. But publicly, for all intents and purposes, patronage was over.
It's gone. It's gone. In the words of Cornell Davis, they said he wasn't dead. So I went to his grave, and I walked around that grave. And I stomped on that grave. And I jumped up and down. And I called out, patronage, patronage, are you alive? And patronage didn't answer. It is dead, dead, dead.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Washington attacked the machine. The machine struck back. From the first day of Washington's first city council meeting, 29 aldermen, all of them white, the old Democratic machine, teamed up to oppose him. For the first time in memory, a Chicago mayor did not control City Hall. It was the machine's 29 votes to Howard's 21 votes. The 29 not only blocked his appointments, it never brought them up for consideration. They blocked most of his legislative initiatives and dedicated enormous energy to looking for ways to embarrass him and thwart him.
It was mayhem, a battle so divisive and chaotic that for years, it sustained the disturbing animosity and suspicion between Black Chicago and white Chicago. Everyone took sides. It came to be known locally as Council Wars, after a local African-American comic named Aaron Freeman began staging moments in local politics as scenes from the Star Wars trilogy.
Harold Washington appeared as Luke Skytalker, leader of the rebellion. Harold's main political opponent, Ed Vrdolyak, the alderman who led the 29, also got a big part.
What are you doing in my office, Lord Darth Vrdolyak?
[LOUD, HEAVY BREATHING]
[CHEERING]
I wish to discuss committee assignments for the new council. [LOUD, HEAVY BREATHING]
I don't have to talk to you. I'm the mayor. I can do whatever I want. I can-- [STRAINED YELL]
[LOUD, HEAVY BREATHING]
[LAUGHTER]
I find your lack of respect disturbing. It is obvious you do not know the power of the clout. It has served all of the mayors before you. It can bring you great wealth and power, or it can destroy you as easily. The choice is yours.
You do not consternate me, Vrdolyak. Take this parliamentary maneuver. [IMITATES LASER MISSILE]
Well done, Mayor. But I counter with this negotiated majority. [IMITATES LASER MISSILE]
Then I file a suit in court. [IMITATES LASER MISSILE]
But the decision is in my favor. [IMITATES LASER MISSILE]
[SHRIEKS] You may have prevailed at this juncture, Vrdolyak, but I will assiduously pursue your disestablishment.
[LOUD, HEAVY BREATHING] Perhaps, Mayor. But to do so, you must use the dark side of the clout. You must make deals and compromises.
Never.
Yes, Mayor. To defeat me, you must become me. Look at my face, Skytalker, for I am your mentor.
No.
[CHEERING]
Even under these adverse conditions, Washington did manage to pass budgets and get some things done. Black wards finally got the same street repair and garbage pickup is all the other words. Jacky Grimshaw describes one scheme Washington came up with to do some improvements around the city, designed to be, of course, fairer than fair, to give every word the same benefits. But the 29, of course, opposed it. And Washington needed their approval because to pay for it, he wanted to issue a city bond.
So every ward was to get-- I think it was 10 miles of street resurfacing and a certain number of alleys done and street lighting. And so he had all these on the bond issue, and they were refusing to pass it. So he put all of the reporters on a bus. And he would go around to these various wards. And we went out to Mount Greenwood, another area of the city that did not welcome Blacks at the time, to say, your alderman is refusing to support this bond issue that I want to use to give you real streets. And if you want it, you better tell your alderman to vote for it.
And so by the time he got through doing this, the folks in the communities were pretty much outraged. Black mayor or not, they wanted their streets. They wanted their sewers. They wanted their vaulted sidewalks repaired and so forth.
What happens to American politics when one of the politicians happens to be Black? In this case, what happened was that everything in city politics was seen through the prism of race, even though often it had nothing to do with race. Often, it had more to do with reform. Gary Rivlin is the author of a very evenhanded history of Washington's ears, Fire on the Prairie.
Everyone wants to understand Harold Washington is the first Black mayor. And it's true. He's the first Black mayor. And that was a very significant thing. But he was also the mayor who beat the Chicago political machine. He was the first reformer in 30 years to take on the machine. And he did it more successfully than anyone else before him, purely on a reform point of view. And so he was a different kind of politician. But no one could ever see beyond his race.
In fact, there was a political cartoon at the time I loved. And it was an editor asking the reporter covering the election, so, anything change? Anything new? And the reporter answered, nope, he's still white, and he's still Black. And it really wasn't that much more sophisticated than that cartoon indicated.
You pick up a local paper, and these guys just wax so eloquent. They don't know what they're talking about, don't have the slightest idea about the phenomena, don't understand the history, don't understand the mindset, don't understand what push people. All they say is, gee, Black folks must be angry.
[LAUGHTER]
Gee, Black folks vote for Black folks. They must hate white folks. That ain't got nothing to do with nothing, nothing, crazy stuff. That's what you read around here in Chicago. That's what I have to put up with every day when I look in the reporters' eyes, all those silly business. How many white folks did you convert today, Harold?
Wow.
[APPLAUSE]
Wow. And the answer is more than you did, boy. Because I do my job, irregardless of race, color, creed, and sex.
Because everything he did, even things that were more about reform than about race, was seen through the lens of race, it gave Washington's opponents a tool that they could use against him, which they did. A typical example-- some crime rates went up between 1985 and '86, even though overall, crime was lower under Washington than under his white predecessor. But his opponents tried to make the case that this proved the Black mayor did not care about crime. Hate literature had said that he would do nothing about crime because most crime is caused by Blacks.
So they were using this statistical bump between '85 and '86 to prove what the hate literature was saying, that the Black mayor's going to be indifferent to crime. See, that's playing the race card and playing it in a dirty way. It's a way of distorting statistics to play to racial fears out there.
So did Washington talk about race? Did he talk about the Chicago political machine always being biased against the Black community? Sure. Is that playing the race card? Sure. But I also happen to think it's true, what he was saying, whereas what I think the opposition was doing much more of was playing the race card and playing it in a dirty way, trying to tweak and abuse statistics any way they could to prove their point and play into the worst fears of the white community. I never saw Washington playing into the worst fears of the Black community. In fact, his rhetoric was, I'm going to be fairer than fair.
The fact is, by the time he died, just a few months into his second term of office, Harold Washington had put together a working majority on the council. Not many more whites voted for him in his second election than in his first. But every political observer in Chicago says that he was making headway. Patrick O'Connor was one of the 29 alderman who opposed Washington that was one of the few swing votes who sometimes sided with the mayor.
We invited him up to a picnic in our ward. And he showed up at our picnic. And he got a great reception. People that really didn't vote for him, and probably wouldn't vote for him the next time, respected the fact that he came out there, that he wanted to say hello, that he wanted to participate. And bear in mind that I was voting consistently with a block that was voting against him. And he came out, and we spent the day, and it was fine.
I remember, one time, we were both invited to a place that neither of us were particularly popular in the ward. And so I got a call from his office-- and this is, again, at a time when there was a counsel war going on-- asking, was I going to this festival or whatever it was? And if I was, would I meet the mayor on a corner in our ward and go in there together with him? And I told the guy, no, I'm not meeting him on the corner. I said, he wants me to go, he's going to pick me up at my house.
So the mayor pulls up to the front of my house. He comes in. We have-- a glass of wine, he had, and I had a beer. We sat around for a couple of minutes. And he met my family. And he looks in my dining room. We didn't have any dining room furniture at the time. The kids were all young, and we'd just moved into the house. So he says, where's your dining room furniture? My wife says, you don't pay him enough money. And Harold goes, I knew this cheese was going to cost me something. And he was just that quick. He was really very, very good.
But my point is, is that we got in the car. We went to this festival. And by the time he left, he had people dancing with him. He went over. He was talking with folks. By the time he left, it might not have changed the mind of everybody in there, that he was OK, but he made a significant impact. And he understood, by keeping that schedule and going through areas where he was not expected to show up or would traditionally not be the most welcome person, that he was winning percentages of people. And that's all he had to do.
Vernon Jarrett says that if Washington had lived, he would have done a lot to ease the strains of modern Chicago apartheid.
Harold was going to win over a big chunk of the white population. And I don't mean Gold Coast liberals. They were beginning to like this guy. And they could see something in him that represented them. He was chubby, warm, friendly. And not only that, he was going into some lower-class white neighborhoods, having their streets paved for the first time. And they were slowly beginning to lose their fear.
Act Two, "The Present and the Future."
There are ways, I think, that the mayor has changed the city forever, but they're not things you can necessarily measure by doing headcounts and using a lot of numbers.
Laura Washington, Harold's former press secretary, now editor at a sort of muckraking publication called The Chicago Reporter.
I think he opened up the city in ways that it will never be closed again. If you look at the numbers, you'll still see a lot of inequity. You'll still see neighborhoods that are poorer, probably poorer than they were 15, 20 years ago. You'll see neighborhoods that still probably don't get their fair share of city services. But you'll see, I think, a dramatic difference in the attitude the public officials and policymakers have to equity in the city.
10 years after Harold Washington's death, people who follow politics in Chicago say that, if nothing else, the current mayor, Richard M. Daley, son of Richard J, has to worry about making Black voters angry. He's been careful to have Black press secretaries and kept a number of appointees from the Black administration before him. He's done nothing so far to infuriate Black Chicago the way his white predecessors regularly did.
City services are distributed more fairly, even today. There's been a bit of backsliding here and there. And Richard Daley's latest proposed bond issue follows the model of the Washington years. It gives all of Chicago's wards equal benefits, something that was unheard of in the years before Washington.
It's been 10 years since Harold Washington's death. And the nation's three largest cities-- New York, Chicago, Los Angeles-- no longer have Black mayors. This is partly a coincidence, no viable candidates in the right positions. Mayor Bradley in Los Angeles stepped down from office. Mayor Dinkins in New York was simply not a strong citywide candidate. Harold had a heart attack. White and Black politicians in Chicago agree that, had Harold Washington lived, he could have stayed mayor, as he often joked, for 20 years. We would be in our 14th year of his administration right now.
10 years after Harold Washington's death, we have Black mayors in cities with tiny Black populations, like Seattle and Denver and Minneapolis, and Black mayors in cities with big populations, like Washington, DC and Atlanta. And Michael Dawson, director of the University of Chicago's Research Center for the Study of Race, Politics, and culture, defines the trend this way.
Well, there's two types of cities that African-American candidates, or two types of electoral jurisdictions where African-American candidates do very well. Black mayors do well when there's either a very small Black population or a very large Black population and tend to have more difficulty winning in that middle range, where Blacks are viewed as a threat within the city, but where they're not a decisive part of the voting coalition. But in general, when Blacks represent between approximately 15% to 20% of the population to slightly above 50% of the population, that's the most difficult and polarized setting for an African-American to run.
When the population is in that range, as it is here in Chicago, when a Black candidate enters the race, it's very hard for him to be seen as anything but the Black candidate. Racial sides are taken, just as happened during Harold Washington's life. And even if the candidate tries to reassure white voters by constantly talking about fairness, by treating them fairly, it can still be enormously difficult to win them over. At the end of Harold Washington's first term, 88% of white voters still voted against him in the re-election.
When I asked the people who urged Harold Washington to run in the first place and organized and registered voters-- this is Lu Palmer and Timuel Black-- what the lessons of the Washington years are for us today, they both said the same thing-- to organize. The reason why there's been no Black mayor since Washington, elected here in Chicago, is that the organization that created him vanished once he took office.
And I'll tell you, a lot of people don't like to criticize Harold Washington. I blame Harold for this.
What should have been happening-- we should have anticipated either his demise or removal from office and been organizing for that possibility.
Harold was put on a pedestal. And I think that was a major mistake. We lifted him to almost god status.
10 years later, in most of Black Chicago, this is still how he's seen among people old enough to remember him. But just as it was during his life, after Washington's death, the two Chicagos remember him differently. As to the hearts and minds of white Chicagoans 10 years after the death of Harold Washington and whether they would vote for a Black mayor today, we sent out Rachel Howard on a fact-finding mission to a white ward on the city's northwest side.
I walked into Fishman and Sons because I liked the sign, red neon letters surrounded by red light bulbs, the biggest sign on the block. This is the 39th Ward, not far from O'Hare Airport, an overwhelmingly white ward that never supported Washington. Inside the bar, the first man I asked about Harold Washington got angry. That nigger, he yelled. What the hell do you want to know about that nigger for? I decided not to ask if he voted for him.
[INDISTINCT CHATTER]
This guy was part of a whole row of men in their late 50s who were eager to talk about Washington, but never on tape. They would start ranting about how he should have stayed on the South Side, how he was a faggot, how he wasn't their mayor. Then, after about a minute, they'd stop, look at me, and say, don't get me started. 10 years is not a very long time. I kept moving around the bar until I finally came to a couple of younger guys in their 40s who let me tape them.
No, I didn't vote for Harold at all.
Why not?
Because he was Black.
Most people I spoke with felt this way. Some even said they were scared when Harold was elected. And in another bar up the street, a guy explained what everyone had been afraid of.
We thought, that's it. We're done. And that was a big thing. I mean, North Side's going to be a South Side now. See, the North Side and South Side are very segregated.
Put it this way. He thought that--
That Black people are going to take over the city.
Not that. Those slums, be slums. You worry about slums.
This guy was about 35, grew up in the area, still lives there. One of his buddies he was playing pool with, who couldn't stop staring at my breasts, started complaining about Blacks getting more city jobs unfairly. And the first guy cut in.
But I tell you what I realized, though, is, you're always worried about race. A Black guy being a Black mayor is like, it doesn't matter. The guy did a lot for us. He did a lot for everybody, not just for white people. I'm going to say he did a lot for everybody, it really made me think that, hey. Unfortunately, I feel bad because I didn't vote for the guy. But after he died and you realize what happened, and the new mayors came in, new regimes came in and all that-- until he died, you finally realize, you know what? He was a damn good mayor.
The North Side city was a really nice city, white. I mean, I say it's white, but it's a very clean city. And all of a sudden, now we have new streets. Taxes never really went up that much. And it's like, until he was gone, you finally realize, hey, he actually did something for us. My parents say the same thing, goes, son of a gun. He goes, you know what? The best mayor we ever had was Mayor Washington. And you know what, though? We'd never vote for the guy.
[INDISTINCT CHATTER]
I asked his friend if he thought this too, that things in the ward improved under Harold Washington. He shook his head. He didn't answer.
Every group-- if the press is listening, I want them to hear this. They didn't hear it when I ran for office. I'll say it again. Every group, when it gets population ascendancy, as night follows day, decide, without malice to anybody, not angering anybody, that it is their turn, period. That's all. Ain't nothing wrong with that.
[APPLAUSE]
I made that statement two months ago, and they said it was racist. But they left out most of the statements, which the Irish do it. And the Polish do it. And the Jews do it. And every intelligent group on Earth, which is every group, does it. And we do it. And we should do it. And we do it in a positive sense, not in a negative sense.
You're not anti-Irish because you're pro-Black. You're not anti-Black because you're pro-Jewish. That doesn't follow. You just happen to be pro. And as long as you are not anti, as long as you are not anti, your pro-ism is acceptable. So it's just that simple. Now I hope the press gets it right just once.
[CHEERING]
Let's give the last word today to Judge Pincham.
I just happen to be one who believes that, again, the power structure does this-- make heroes out of dead folks-- because dead folks can't lead nobody nowhere. They've made Dr. King a holiday. And he was the most unpopular person at the time of his death of any leader in the history of the nation. And the moment he got killed, since he can't lead nobody nowhere, now he's a hero.
And Harold?
I don't think that they're going to give Harold the same kind of accolades because he might lead somebody from the grave.
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, Nancy Updike, Alix Spiegel, and Julie Snyder, senior editor Paul Tough, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and [INAUDIBLE] Sarah Vowell, production help from Rachel Howard.
We used archival footage today from the following sources-- from Brian Boyer's film, Harold Washington and the Council Wars, which makes its local debut here in Chicago on WTTW in February, from Bill Cameron's taped recordings of Harold Washington's speeches and press conferences. We got tape from Chicago's Museum of Broadcast Communications, thanks to Bruce DuMont and the staff there, also from Howard Gladstone and Jim Ylisela's film, The Race For Mayor, from Bill Stamet's film, Chicago Politics-- A Theater of Power, from WBBM-TV''s Archival news footage.
WXYT Radio gave us archival tape of Aaron Freeman's Council Wars satire. WTTW-TV gave us archival footage of the 1983 debates. In addition, we'd like to thank Eva Baeza, director of the Chernin Center for the Arts at the Duncan YMCA. Thanks to Gary Rivlin, who gave us advice throughout this production. We recommend his book, Fire on the Prairie. It's a history of the Washington years. His most recent book is called Drive By.
Thanks to Hugo Tyrel and Dolores woods. And thanks to all the people who we interviewed. Every one of them said so much more of interest than we could possibly fit into an hour radio program. If you would like to buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago. The phone number, 312-832-3380. Again, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] .
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Funding for our program has been provided by the Corporation for Public Broadcasting, the John D. and Catherine T. MacArthur Foundation, and the listeners of WBEZ Chicago. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass.
["CHICAGO" BY FRANK SINATRA] Bet your bottom dollar you lose the blues in Chicago, Chicago
Let us close out today with a recording from the night of Harold Washington's second mayoral victory.
(SINGING) On State Street, that great street, I just want to say
They do things they don't do on Broadway
They have the time, the time of their life
I saw a man
He danced with his wife
In Chicago, Chicago, my hometown
PRI, Public Radio International.